a program that you uh lectured to
five several times um
spoke of that in fact they had filed a a
brief
in lawrence versus texas uh
supporting uh in support of state laws
punishing private
homosexual activity they celebrated when
india restored a law punishing sodomy of
10 years in
prison now i don't whether you believe
that being gay is right or wrong
is irrelevant to me
but my concern is what you
you work with an organization working to
criminalize
people from uh for loving
a person that they are in love with so
that that's what uh
that's what worried me
did did you i wasn't sure if you wanted
me to answer that
um you know mike's
my experience with the blackstone
program at which i spoke was a wonderful
one
it gathers you know best and brightest
christian lawsuits from around law
students from around the country
and as you said i gave a one-hour
lecture
on originalism i didn't read all of the
material that the students were given to
read that had nothing to do with my
lecture
i enjoyed teaching the students about
what my specialty was which is
constitutional law
and nothing about any of my interactions
with anyone
involved in the blackstone program were
ever indicative of any kind of
discrimination on the basis of anything
well as you know same-sex marriage for
example
and senator feinstein mentioned this at
the beginning
because lego certainly illegal in my
state has been for some time
uh do you feel that should be a crime
same-sex marriage yes obergefell
clearly says that there is a
constitutional right to same-sex
marriage
and do you agree with that uh star
decisis
well senator for the reasons that i've
already said i'm not gonna as justice
kagan put it give a thumbs up or thumbs
down to any particular precedent it's
president of the supreme court
that gives same-sex couples the right to
marry
well you mentioned justice kate and she
once wrote an
opinion that is not enough that five
justices believe
a precedent is wrong reversing course
demands a special justification
over and above the belief that the
president was wrongly decided do you
agree with that
i do agree with that the doctrine of
starry decisis itself requires that
you
having relied on steroids in many of my
arguments before
courts of appeals i thank you for your
answer
um chief justice roberts senator leahy
uh i don't mean interrupt i know you
don't have a clock in front of you but
we're about a
little over a minute over so i'm sorry
i missed it miss chairman i i do not
have a question no i understand i
totally understand
i appreciate it and i will look forward
to the next round of questioning
thank you we'll make sure that happens
very briefly before i go to
senator cornyn senator lee mentioned my
time with the president i think probably
all of us on this side were
consulted by the president regarding how
to fill the opening
he gave me a list of a small list of
names all women you were on and i was
enthusiastic about
everybody i'm very enthusiastic about
your nomination about the president
uh play a lot of golf with the president
i guess uh
i've enjoyed it we talk about a lot on
the golf course
some policy killing suleimani we talked
about that that was an interesting
discussion
i promise you i've never talked about
severability with the president
good morning your honor good morning
senator cornyn
you know most of us have multiple
notebooks and notes and books and things
like that in front of us can you hold up
what you've been referring to and
answering
our questions
is there anything on it uh that
letterhead that says united states
senate
that's imp that's impressive
well judge um
the best i can understand the objections
to your nomination or not to your
qualifications your experience
or training but it's that you have or
you will
violate your oath of office
i find that terribly insulting
they suggest that you can't be unbiased
in deciding a case you haven't even
participated in yet
i found that insulting as well
you know almost as maybe almost as
pernicious
as attacking somebody for their faith
and suggesting that that disqualifies
them from
holding a public office
is the attack that's being made on
judicial independence
something that chief justice rehnquist
among others
observed the crown jewels of the
american constitution and the american
system
but i want to just take a little walk
down memory lane here
you know there are a lot of a lot of
people who guessed
how judges would actually rule on cases
and almost always they've been
spectacularly wrong
i was struck by uh by just a couple of
harry truman said whenever you put a man
and that he's talking
about a man but a man or woman on the
supreme court he ceases to be your
friend
he said some more colorful things too
but theodore roosevelt said about oliver
wendell holmes jr he said
i could carve out a bin out of a banana
a judge with more backbone than that and
as i think about people like
harry blackmon nominated by richard
nixon
who wrote roe versus wade
as i think about warren berger you know
they were called the minnesota twins
and obviously over time they became sort
of polar opposites
on the court i think about the attacks
on neil gorsuch
for his unwillingness to make a
preview a prior commitment on lgbt
issues he wrote the bostock case
extending title seven of the civil
rights act
to gay or transgender individuals
obviously
those predictions were wrong
and then since we're talking about the
aca
it's the aca versus acb i guess
chief justice roberts was the one who
wrote the opinion upholding
the affordable care act as you know
so i would just say that all of these
predictions about how
judges under our
independent judiciary will make
decisions
are just pure speculation but i think
they're worse than speculation
i think they're propaganda in order to
try to make a political point
so judge you're not willing to make a
deal
no senator cornyn i'm not willing to
make a deal not with the committee
not with the president not with anyone
i'm independent
i just would like to hear maybe some of
your thoughts on
in the over fell case which established
as you said a constitutional right to
same-sex marriage
part of that decision struck down the
defense of marriage act
correct uh yes i believe so
that was a bill that joe biden
voted for i don't know well i
i do okay joe biden voted for it pat
leahy and bill clinton signed it into
law
can you just i'm not asking you to get
into the details but just sort of
differentiate for everybody listening
what the approach of a legislator is
in voting for a piece of legislation as
opposed to the role of a judge
in interpreting the constitutionality of
a of a
piece of legislation are they the same
are they different they're quite
different
um a judge isn't expressing a policy
view
you know i i tell my students in
constitutional law
that newspapers do courts of disservice
when you know they say things like you
know court
favors same-sex marriage or you know
just giving the headline without showing
any of the reasoning that goes
into it because courts are not just
expressing a policy preference
they're digging in they're looking at
the precedent they're looking at the
constitution and
even when the result cuts against policy
preferences
judges are obliged to follow them i
suspect that this body
doesn't cast votes that conflict with
their policy preferences
well that's right and the difference
between us and you is uh
you don't run for election that's right
you don't
run on a platform you don't say if i'm
confirmed
i'm gonna do this or that you don't do
that do you it would be
wholly wildly inappropriate for me to do
so
well your mentor justice scalia said
something back in 2005 that i
i find intriguing
but reassuring he said if you're going
to be a good
and faithful judge you have to resign
yourself to the fact that you're not
always going to like
the conclusions you reach if you like
them all the time
you're probably doing something wrong
do you agree with that and if you do
would you explain what you mean
i do agree with that and that you know
has been my experience
on the seventh circuit so far it's your
job
to pass the statutes it's your job to
choose
policy and then it's my job to
interpret those laws and apply them to
facts of particular cases
and they don't always lead me to results
that i would reach if i were
you know queen of the world and i could
say you win
you lose or this is how i want it to be
because i just don't have the power
by fiat to impose my policy preferences
or choose
the result i prefer that's just not my
role i've got to go with what
you guys have chosen well why in the
world would the american people
surrender their right to govern
themselves
through their elected representatives
and through the constitution to nine
people
who don't even run for election and who
serve for life why in the world would
should the american people do that well
i think part of the rationale
for courts adhering to the rule of law
and for judges taking great care to
avoid imposing their policy preferences
is that it's inconsistent with democracy
nobody wants to live in accord with the
law of amy i'm sure my children don't
even want to do that
so i can't as a judge get up on the
bench
and say you're going to live by my
policy preferences because i have life
tenure and you can't kick me out if you
don't like them
well thankfully under the constitution
even if the supreme court
strikes down a statute congress can come
back and revisit that topic
and do so in a way that doesn't violate
the constitution
as determined by the court and
ultimately
it doesn't happen very often in our
history but ultimately we can amend the
constitution itself correct
that is correct so the the basis of
legitimacy
of governmental power is consent of the
governed do you agree with that
i do agree with that not what nine
people in black robes
the high nine on the potomac i think
they're sometimes called
the decisions they make those are that's
not the final word in our
form of government correct we are a a
law
um a government of laws not of men
well judge barrett i'm almost through
but i i can't pass up the opportunity to
ask you a question about the
establishment clause
uh i did with uh justice kavanaugh and
justice gorsuch as well
it's borne out of my frustration uh
one of the couple of times i had a
chance as attorney general
of texas to argue before the supreme
court i argued in a case called santa fe
independent school district versus doe
this was about a commonplace
practice where the forest football games
in texas
students would volunteer to offer a
invocation or an inspirational
poem or saying or something like that
the aclu
sued the school district and obviously
it made its way all the way all the way
to the supreme court
and i'm not going to ask you your
opinion
on the outcome of the case but what
troubles me
the most what troubled me the most about
that experience is when the
supreme court struck down or held that
practice
unconstitutional and in violation of the
establishment clause
chief justice rehnquist said the
constitution
requires neutrality toward religion
but the court's approach
speaks of hostility toward religion
could you just talk a little bit about
the establishment clause
generally with not in regard to any
particular set of facts but
sort of what what the courts over time
have tried to do
to to uh to enforce the mandate of the
constitution
well senator cornyn when i interviewed
for my job with justice scalia
he asked what area of the court's
precedent
that i thought you know needed to be
better organized or
that sort of thing and off the cuff i
said well gosh the first amendment
and he said well what do you mean and i
fell down a rabbit hole of trying to
explain without success because it is a
very complicated area of the law
how one might see one's way through the
thicket of
balancing the establishment clause
against the free exercise clause it's a
notoriously different
difficult area of the law and to the
extent that you know there is tension in
the court's cases
um and i'm giving you no better an
answer i assure you than i did to
justice scalia that day
it's been something that the court has
struggled with you know for decades to
try to come to a sensible way
to apply both of those clauses
well i wish you well thank you senator
mr chairman i'm going to reserve the
rest of my time thank you senator cornyn
uh for planning purposes
if it's okay with the committee uh we'll
have senator durbin and senator lee will
break uh for about a half hour for lunch
and quebec center in the white house
is that okay senator durbin are you okay
with that do you need a break no that's
fine
okay thank you mr chairman
and thank you judge barrett and your
family for being here with us today
for this marathon questioning
thank you senator durbin appreciate it i
would like to respond to my colleagues
quickly before i
ask a few questions of you how who came
up with this notion this insulting
notion that you might violate your
oath where could this idea have come
from
could it have come from the white house
could have come from the president's
tweets
of what he expects the supreme court
nominee to do politically for him
that's where it comes from that's where
it originated
and you have said very clearly today
without equivocation
you are not going to be influenced by
president trump's importuning
or the importance of this committee or
anyone else which is what we expect you
to say but this notion that this
whole idea of your being used for
political purposes
is a democratic creation read the tweets
and you have plenty to work with read
the tweets
the second thing i would like to say is
i'm not going to spend a lot of time
uh defending the affordable care act
although i think it's the most important
single vote i've cast
as a member of congress period but i
will say
that when the chairman opened up on it
and said what he did
i was puzzled three states get 35
percent of the money how can that
possibly be true
well it turns out because those states
decided to extend
medicaid coverage to the people who live
in the states and his
did not and as a consequence fewer
people in
south carolina have the protection of
health insurance
and those that do are paying for their
services
and those that don't or not which
imperils
hospitals and others in the process so i
would say there is an explanation as to
why
some states are spending more and
incidentally
there was a republican governor of your
state indiana by the name of mike pence
who decided to break with other
republican governors
and extend medicaid coverage under the
affordable care act i think was the
right thing to do
for indiana as it was for illinois but
that's part of the reasoning
let me just say that the affordable care
act really is at the heart of this as
you can tell
on the democratic side we really believe
the supreme court's consideration of
that case
is going to could literally change
america
for millions of people i have with me
today
another group i'd like you to at least
be aware of because they're
pretty amazing people but um
this is the williams family they live in
naperville not too far from
chicago yeah kathy and les williams have
four sons from left to right matt
joey tommy and mikey matt who's 27
was diagnosed with type 1 diabetes when
he was 13.
the other three williams boys were all
born with cystic fibrosis
joey is 24 mike he's 21 sadly mikey's
twin and tommy
after this picture was taken passed away
in january 2019 for complications
this is the last photo was ever taken of
their full family
here's what they wrote me we cannot
imagine having to go through losing
another child
people with cystic fibrosis require
daily medication regular doctor visits
access to high quality specialized care
that means people with pre-existing
conditions like cystic fibrosis
cannot be discriminated against the
aca's protections ensure a ban
on annual and lifetime caps and enforce
the requirement that insurers cover
essential health benefits
such as hospitalizations or mental
health services
people with cf and other pre-existing
conditions need adequate
affordable health care to live longer
healthier lives
that's why we keep bringing this up real
people that we run into all the time
there's a chart here i'm not sure too
while we're at it
on the republican side there's some
obvious controversy as to whether we're
right or wrong
but they're an awful lot of people in
each of the states represented by our
republican senators
who have their health care and
literally in some cases their lives
hanging in the balance
south carolina 242 000 people would lose
their insurance coverage if the
affordable care act were eliminated
two million living in that state have
pre-existing conditions you can imagine
the list goes on thank you
here's what it comes down to you've been
unequivocal and being critical of the
decisions
both in nfib sebelius and the king
burwell
and we naturally draw the conclusion
there's going to be a third strike when
it comes to
texas and california you said it won't
affect pre-existing conditions
if the petitioners have their way
there will not be an affordable care act
to protect pre-existing conditions
on the severability question so give us
an insight
how you can be so unequivocal in
opposing the
majority decisions in nfiv sibelius
and in king and burwell but have an open
mind when it comes to the future of the
affordable care act
sure thank you for that question senator
durbin because it gives me an
opportunity to make my position clear
um when i wrote and at this was as a law
professor
about those decisions i did critique
the statutory interpretation of the
majority opinions and as i
mentioned before my description of them
was consistent with the way that chief
justice roberts described
the statutory question but i think
that your concern is that because
i critiqued the statutory reasoning that
i'm hostile
to the aca and that because i'm hostile
to the aca
that i would decide a case a particular
way
and i assure you that i am not i'm not
hostile to the aca i'm not
hostile to any statute that you pass
and the cases on which i commented and
we can talk at another time i guess
about the context the distinctions
between academic writing and judicial
decision making
but those were on entirely different
issues so to assume that because
i critiqued the interpretation of the
mandate
or the phrase established by a state
means that on the entirely different
legal question of severability
i would reach a particular result just
assume that i'm hostile
and that's not the case i apply the law
i follow the law you make the policy
so let's talk about that for a moment
from a different issue perspective
bear with me for a couple questions have
you seen the george floyd video
i have what impact did it have on you
um senator as you might imagine
given that i have two black children
that was very
very personal for my family um
jessie was with the boys on a camping
trip
out in south dakota so i was there and
my
17 year old daughter vivian who was
adopted from haiti
all of this was erupting it was very
difficult for her
um we wept together in my room and then
it was also difficult
for my daughter julia who's ten i had to
try to explain some of this
to them i mean my children to this point
in their lives have had the benefit of
growing up in a cocoon where they have
not yet experienced
hatred or violence um and for vivian
you know to understand that there would
be a risk to her brother or the son she
might have one day
of that kind of brutality
has been an ongoing conversation it's a
difficult one for us like it is for
americans all over the country
and so i'd like to ask you as an
originalist who obviously
has a passion for history i can't
imagine that you could separate the two
to reflect on the history of this
country where are we today
when it comes to the issue of race some
argue
it's fine everything's fine and you
don't have to even teach
children about the history of slavery or
discrimination others say there's
implicit bias in so many aspects
of american life that we have to be very
candid about and address
others go further and say no it's
systemic racism that's built into
america
and we have to be much more pointed in
our
our addressing how do you feel
so i think it is an entirely
uncontroversial and obvious statement
given as we just talked about the george
floyd video
that racism persists in our country
as to putting my finger on the nature of
the problem
you know whether as you say it's just
outright or systemic racism
or how to tackle the prop the issue of
making it better
those things you know are policy
questions
they're hotly contested policy conduct
uh questions
that have been in the news and discussed
all summer
so while you know as i did share my
personal experience i'm very
you know happy to discuss the reaction
our family had to the george floyd video
giving broader statements or making you
know
broader diagnoses about the problem
of racism is kind of beyond
what i'm capable of doing as a judge
well i
i would doubt that i just don't believe
you can be as passionate about
originalism and the history behind
language that we've had for decades if
not centuries
without having some thought about where
we stand today but i'm not going to
press you on that
i'm going to take you to a case which uh
i have read and reread
cantor versus bar and you know the case
well because it's all
already been referred to and it it
clearly is a case where you had your day
in court
you wrote the sole dissent uh the
64-page case 37 pages were your dissent
so you gave to the court i assume a
pretty full
accounting of your thoughts on the
subject and here's the way i understand
the case
a felony fellow named ricky cantor from
macquain wisconsin
invented some pads to put in a shoe
to be sold to particularly older
americans under medicare
to relieve foot pain and he designed
them
and submitted them to medicare and
didn't get the approval that he was
looking for
but instead sold them and represented to
many customers that they had been
approved by medicare
and so he was charged with fraud now
this wasn't a matter of a casual
uh mis misapplication of the law
when it was all said and done ricky
cantor of mcquan wisconsin
ended up spending over a year a year and
a day in federal prison
paying somewhere near 300 000 in
penalties and fines
and 27 million dollars in a civil
settlement on this issue so this was not
a
casual wrongdoing this man was a
swindler
and he was taking the federal government
for a ride as well as well as other
customers and misleading senior citizens
about his product and paid a heavy price
for it
then he decided having left prison that
it's just fundamentally unfair
that the law says that if you've been
convicted of a felony you can't own a
firearm
now i don't know what his appetite is
when it comes to firearms whether it's a
revolver or an ak-47 with a banana clip
i have no idea but he went to court and
said this is unfair
it was just mail fraud and you're taking
away my second amendment rights
so two out of three of your colleagues
then
basically said sorry ricky you have
forfeited your right to own a firearm
because of your conviction of a felony
you took a different approach exactly
the opposite approach
and went deep into history i think the
earliest
citation i see here was 1662
to figure out just what was going on
here and whether or not
he had to have committed a violent
felony to have forfeited this right
to own a firearm have i stated the facts
close to what you remember i don't
remember the amount of the loss some of
those details but
yes ricky cantor was convicted of
selling fraudulent shoe inserts and it
was a felony
27 million dollar settlement along the
way so
i'd like to take you into your thinking
on this when heller decision was handed
down
justice scalia expressly said
i'm not taking away the authority of
government
to impose limitations based on felonies
not violent felonies felonies and mental
illness
he said as much and held her decision
and yet
this man who was your inspiration as
you've told us all
uh you decided he was wrong and that it
had to be a violent felony can you
explain why
i can so we've talked about precedent
and in my court the seventh circuit
there is precedent saying that that
phrase doesn't control
as you know my colleague judge frank
easter brook has said a number of times
that judicial opinions aren't statutes
and shouldn't be read as if they were so
heller obviously wasn't about the scope
of the right
you know its application to felons or
those who are mentally ill etc and so
that
passage was dicta it didn't fully dive
down
into it but what i did was apply
heller's methodology
both justice scalia's majority opinion
and justice stephen's dissent
used an originalist methodology to
answer that question
and i concluded that based on that
history
one couldn't take the right away simply
because one was a felon
that there had to be a showing of
dangerousness and i didn't rule out the
possibility that the government
might be able to make that showing about
ricky cantor
but i think we could all agree that we
ought to be careful of saying that
because someone's a felon they lose any
of their individual rights
i want to get to that point but i'd like
to stick with this for just a moment
more
um i'm honored to represent the city of
chicago and the state of illinois
it's a great city but it has great
problems too
and one of them is gun violence on the
average
we know in america a hundred americans
are killed every day by gunfire forty
thousand per year
in the city of chicago more than three
thousand two hundred people have been
shot just this year
three thousand two hundred according the
city's gun trace report in 2017
the majority of the illegally used or
possessed firearms recovered in chicago
are traced back to states with less
regulation over firearms
such as indiana in mississippi
the 2017 report found that indiana alone
was the source of 21 percent of all
chicago's recovered crime guns
we know how it works where you live you
know how it works there's a traffic
between chicago and northern indiana and
michigan going on constantly
gun shows are held in gary indiana and
other places
and when they're selling these firearms
without background checks
unfortunately these gang bangers and
thugs fill up the trunks of their cars
with firearms and head into the city of
chicago
and kill everyone from infants to older
people it's just
it's a horrific situation law
enforcement is fighting it trying to get
indiana to at least do background checks
at these gun shows
with limited success and we are trying
to apply the standards that you
disqualify yourself
by buying a firearm to felonies
and mental illness and you want to take
away
part of that protection with your
decision
in this case because if you eliminate
felonies and just confine it to violent
felonies
you're opening up more opportunities for
people to buy firearms are you not
well senator you referred to gang
members and thugs
um buying guns in indiana and taking
them across the border
and certainly that if they if they had
felony convictions for doing the kinds
of things that
members of gangs and thugs do nothing in
canter says that the government can't
deprive them of firearms and nothing
says in my opinion that the government
can't deprive ricky cantor of having
firearms they simply had to make a
showing of dangerousness
before they did so and nothing in the
opinion opines at all
on the legality of background checks and
gun licensing those are all separate
issues but the majority zeros in and
says what you've just said
is totally impractical that we are going
to go case by case and decide well what
kind of felonies and what kind of person
and then they go on to produce evidence
i can read the numbers here but you know
them well because you wrote the dissent
where the likelihood of committing a
violent felony after being
convicted of a felony is pretty dramatic
and they're saying to us don't let us
don't force us to make it case by case
we want to make it by category it's the
only practical way to deal with the
thousands
if not millions of people who are buying
firearms
you are aware of the fact that even
those who are so-called not
violent felons quote only felons like
ricky cantor
have a propensity to create to commit
violent felonies in the future are you
not
there was no evidence of that in the
case and we
on courts for example the armed career
criminal act
that's a federal statute have to make
judgments
categorically all the time about what
count as crimes of violence
um so i don't think that's beyond the
can of courts
in any area to identify which felonies
are violent and you know which felonies
are not
excuse me but i won't address that issue
let's go to page 21 of the opinion
and what the court said the majority in
the court most felon
they quoted yancey most felons are
non-violent but someone with felony
conviction on his record is more likely
than a non-felon to engage in illegal
and violent gun use
for example one study this goes on to
say 210
886 non-violent offenders found that one
out of five were rearrested for a
violent crime within three years
so the evidence is there it is there for
the court to consider
and you ignored it senator i didn't
ignore it
um as i recall that evidence and the
studies
were unclear um it and
let's see i can't remember as i'm
sitting here
the details of all the statistics but i
did consider it and i recall saying
something in the opinion
about the reliability of those studies
because they didn't say whether someone
had been convicted of a
non-violent crime but had later been
convicted of a
violent crime as well i mean felonies
cover a broad range of things
including selling pigs without a license
in some states
redeeming too many bottle caps in
michigan
i mean so felonies now cover broad swath
of conduct
not all of which seems indicative of
whether someone's likely to abuse a
firearm
so let's let me take you i'm not going
to go
so far back in history but i'm i'm going
to take you back in history for a moment
and note that when that second amendment
was written
and you did the analysis of it we were
talking about the likelihood that a
person could purchase a muzzle loading
musket
we are now talking about virtual
military weapons
that can kill hundreds of innocent
people it is a much different
circumstance maybe an originalist
pins all their thinking to that musket
but i've got to bring it to the 21st
century
and the 21st century has people being
killed on the streets of chicago
because of the proliferation of deadly
firearms but let me bring it closer to
home
and tie up the george floyd question
with
where i'm headed there's also a question
as whether the commission of a felony
disqualifies you from voting in america
and the history on that is pretty clear
in an article the american journal of
sociology found that many
felony voting bans were passed in the
late 1860s and 1870s
when implementation of the 15th
amendment and its extension of voting
rights to african americans were
ardently contested
it still goes on today with voter
suppression but we know
that in reconstruction in the jim
crow era in black code era
that was used a felony conviction was
used to disqualify
african-americans from voting in south
and
many other places the sentencing project
today
has found that more than six million
americans can't vote because of a felony
conviction
and one out of every 13 black americans
have lost their voting rights
the reason i raised that is that in your
dissent
you said disqualifying a person person
from voting
because of a simple symbol because of a
felony
is okay but when it comes to the
possession of firearms wait a minute
we're talking about the individual right
of a second amendment
what we're talking about in voting is a
civic right a community right however
you defined it i don't get it
so you're saying that a felony should
not disqualify
ricky from buying an ak-47 but using a
felony conviction
someone's passed to deny them the right
to vote is all right
um senator what i said was that
the constitution contemplates that
states
have the freedom to deprive felons of
the right to vote it's expressed in the
constitutional text
but i expressed no view on whether that
was a good idea
whether states should do that and i
didn't explore
in that opinion because it was
completely irrelevant to it what
limits if any there might be on a
state's ability
to curtail felon voting rights did you
not distinguish the second amendment
right
from the right to vote calling one an
individual
right under the constitution and the
other a civic
right that's consistent with the
language in the historical context the
way the briefs
described it and it was part of the
dispute and heller of whether the second
amendment was an individual right
or a civic one that was possessed
collectively
for the sake of the common good and
everybody was treating voting as one of
the civic rights
well i will just tell you that the the
conclusion of this
is hard to swallow the notion that mr
cantor after all that he did
should not be even slowed down when he's
on his way to buy a firearm
my goodness it's just a felony it's not
a violent felony that he committed
and then to turn around on the other
hand and say well but when it comes to
taking away a person's right to vote
that's the civic duty it's something
that we could countenance
that is really goes back to the original
george floyd question
that was thinking in the 19th century
that resulted in voter suppression
and taking away the right to vote from
millions of african americans
across this country and it still
continues to this day
i just don't see it i think the right to
vote should be
given at least as much
respect as any second amendment right do
you
senator the supreme court has repeatedly
said that voting is a fundamental right
and i fear that you might be taking my
statement in canter out of context
what i said in that opinion was
distinguishing between
it was a descriptive statement of the
state of the court's case law
comparing it to felon stripping felons
of second amendment rights
i expressed no view about whether
what the constitutional limits of that
might be or whether the law should
change with respect to felling voting
rights and obviously that's
a contested issue in some states that
are considering it right now and i have
no view on that and it wasn't the
subject of cantor
it may not have been it wasn't the
subject of case that's for sure
but in your writings you raised this it
was part of your dissent discussing the
right to vote and
a felony conviction eliminating it i'm
afraid it's inescapable
you've got to be prepared to answer this
kind of question
i read it and thought i can't imagine
that she's saying this
but i'm afraid i was left with a
suggestion you might
which brings me to the conclusion here
we hear over and over from the other
side of the aisle we don't want any
activist judges
we want judges are going to go back to
the original document
literally take it word for word put it
in a historical context
and don't get in the way of making laws
we make the laws
you're a judge you stay away from them
and yet when we look at this case the
notion of what disqualifies you from
buying a firearm
was being rewritten by the dissenting
judge and saying when we say
felony we just mean violent felony well
the word violent isn't in there
but you found it or at least found
reference to it it's not the only time
this has happened
in citizens united and its progeny
republican appointed justice has struck
down bipartisan campaign finance reform
to unleash a flood of dark money into
our political system
part of that flood is paying for the ad
campaign promoting
your nomination for the supreme court i
know you've said you've gone radio
silent
in following the media i don't blame you
i do the same thing politically
but i can just tell you i've seen them
they are beautiful expensive ads
boosting your nomination for the supreme
court from organizations
we've never heard of spending millions
of dollars to make sure you get on the
supreme court
citizens united opened the door for that
and in shelby county
conservative justices gutted the voting
rights act to unleash a wave of voter
suppression across the country
going back to the george floyd moment
unfortunately a lot of us for racial
purposes
and this is an example two or three
examples that i've given here
activist judges rewriting the law
abolishing the law
people have to get real as i study on
our phone conversation
i don't think you put the facts here in
the law here and nine justices come to
the same conclusion
cases are five four six three seven two
unanimous people see things differently
based on their backgrounds their values
their experience
and i think it's simplistic to think
this is a robotic performance once we
put a judge on the bench they just go
back read the constitution and rule
it's not that simple and i think you've
acknowledged that by saying even
originalists disagree with one another
is that true
yes law is hard and it's complicated and
people who approach it from different
jurisprudential perspectives will
sometimes
reach different results i mean i i think
that's hard to deny because as you say
every vote from the supreme court isn't
unanimous and
sometimes it is but cases don't get to
the supreme court
unless the circuits disagree among
themselves so it's hard
but to the extent senator durbin that
you're suggesting that i have some sort
of agenda
on felon voting rights or guns or
campaign finance or anything else
i can assure you and the whole committee
that i do not
i didn't say that and i wouldn't say
that but i will say that you come
if you're successful in this pursuit you
come to the supreme court with
life experiences you come to the supreme
court having read a lot
i'm sure and drawn some conclusions in
your own mind about certain
things and certain issues everyone on
the court
has that same background they bring
something to it that is just not generic
it's individual and that's the point i'm
making there's an individualism to this
the class of originalists on the supreme
court
are not all going to vote the same on
every case and i think
merely saying originalism does not
absolve you or us
from observing the obvious there are
going to be differences
i think would you like to say something
i don't want to cut you off no that's
okay okay thank you very much
thank you senator senator durbin we'll
uh go to senator lee and after that
we'll take a
30-minute lunch break and start back
with the center of white house
senator lee thank you mr chairman i have
two letters
for the record that i'd like to have
admitted they're authored by
former law clerks of judge barrett's
without objection i'd encourage all
my colleagues to read them they're
outstanding and provide great insight
into
judge barrett's immense qualifications
judge barrett moments ago we went
through
a rather interesting set of exchanges
one of my colleagues i uh i hope i
misunderstood him
seems to have suggested that it's a
political talking point
for you to decline
to indicate how you would rule on a
particular case or a particular type of
case
to the extent that that's what any
colleague has suggested
i'd remind that colleague that's just
wildly incorrect it's wildly incorrect
with canons of judicial ethics
with federal law with the statement laid
out by
justice ruth bader ginsburg in her own
confirmation
proceedings before this very body in
this very room
nearly 30 years ago
it is imperative that you uphold those
standards
and i applaud you for doing so and i
think
on no planet is it appropriate for
anybody
to suggest that that's a political
talking point for you to say i'm not
going to indicate how i'm going to rule
in a particular case justice ginsburg
did in fact say it
well and some of this has been quoted
today i'm going to quote it again just
for good measure she said judges in our
system
are bound to decide concrete cases not
abstract issues
a judge sworn to decide impartially can
offer no forecast no hints
for that would show not only disregard
for the specifics of a particular case
it would display disdain for the entire
judicial process
similarly because you are considering my
capacity
for independent judging my personal
views
on how i would vote on a publicly
debated issue were i in your shoes were
i a legislator
are not what you will be closely
examining that's what she said she said
it well
it was true in 1993 and it remains
true today i want to turn
next to a line of of questioning that
you
just uh finished that you just completed
i too have read the cantor case and
i am thrilled that we've got a jurist
who is willing when looking at somebody
whose constitutional rights are about to
be taken away
thrilled to have a jurist who's willing
to consider
a pre-deprivation review for that
individual
is it unusual judge barrett to consider
someone's constitutional rights on an
individualized basis before having
a specifically enumerated
constitutionally protected right removed
uh that would be very very unusual can
be very very unusual and it would be
unwise would it not
um well i think what i could say to that
just to be careful about
how much law i'm analyzing is that the
14th amendment due process clause
certainly guarantees to each individual
due process before liberty is taken away
i also appreciated the thorough analysis
that you undertook
making clear that our
our rights in this area don't just
date back a few decades they don't just
date back to the 60s they don't date
just back to the
1780s or the 1760s they date back at
least to the
1660s i mean they go way way back
there's a lot of history that went into
what became the second amendment
there were conflicts this involved not
just partisan conflicts
but conflicts between the king and
subjects
and not just between the king and
subjects in the abstract but very often
it was between protestants and catholics
sometimes it was catholics who weren't
trusted with guns
sometimes it was protestants who weren't
trusted with guns but there was a lot of
violence that went into that
and that led to our adoption of that
amendment i appreciated your historical
analysis of this
your willingness to be thorough to make
sure that when someone's
constitutionally protected rights are
taken into account
you're going to do your homework you're
going to do your homework even if it's
hard
you're going to do it even if you've got
colleagues who aren't willing to go
there that's what judicial leadership
is judicial leadership involves
willingness to stand alone
judge barrett one of the things that
came out to me
uh as i read your opinion in the cantor
case
is that your commitment to textualism
and originalism are in fact
real they're not feign this is the kind
of thing you can't fake
this isn't something you make up at the
last minute yes i agree with senator
durbin
being a textualist an originalist
doesn't guarantee a particular result a
particular outcome in any particular
case
but it does indicate a style
a preference tell me why textualism
and originalism are important to you
because i think that both statutes
and the constitution are law
they derive their democratic legitimacy
from the fact that they have been
enacted in the case of statutes by the
people's representatives or in the case
of the constitution
through the constitution-making process
and
i as a judge have an obligation to
respect
and enforce only that law that the
people themselves have embraced
as i was saying earlier it's not the law
of amy it's the law of the american
people
and i think originalism and textualism
to me boil down to that to a commitment
to the rule of law
to not disturbing or changing or
updating
or you know adjusting in line with my
own policy preferences what that law
requires
it is it the subjective motivation the
subjective
intent of an individual lawmaker or
drafter of a constitutional provision
that we're looking at or is it original
public meaning uh and if so what's the
difference between those two
um it's original public meaning not the
subjective
intent of any particular drafter so
one thing i have told my students in
constitutional law is that the question
is not what would james madison do
we don't we're not controlled by how
james madison perceived any particular
problem that's because the law
is what the people understand it to be
not what goes on
in any individual legislatures
legislators mind is
i respect you greatly senator lee but
what you think in your mind rather than
what passes through
both houses and assigned by the
president that's what's the law
not any private intentions you have so
regardless of of
what uh let's say i i passed bill xyz
and uh i'm the sponsor of it i take it
down to the floor
and i say here's bill xyz and here's
what i think about it
here's what i intend to do with it and i
put that statement
into the legislative record what if any
impact should that statement
have on the meaning of law xyz once it
becomes law
um nothing you got to get it into the
law itself if you want it to be law
legislative history is not what goes
through the process of bicameralism and
presentment
regardless of of how passionately and
persuasively i
make that point in whatever glorious
speech i give in support of
bill xyz it doesn't make a darn bit of
difference does it
it doesn't i'm sure the speech would be
glorious but i assume the point you make
probably would be made by the advocates
in the case too
and so in that respect you are
functioning as an advocate when you make
the glorious statement but not speaking
with the voice of the lawmaker because
no
individual does it's the full body
that speaks
i want to speak next about
the affordable care act we we've seen
posters going up
over and over and over again we've seen
them yesterday we've seen them today
we've seen a lot of compelling stories
about
people whose lives have been marked
by difficult things that they've endured
they've involved touching and
heartwarming stories
i continue to doubt the relevance
of things like that here especially in
so far
as they're being used to suggest that
your confirmation to the supreme court
of the united states
has anything to do with their health
care
tell me why you think
that any individual americans
health care status is or is not
tied to your confirmation to the supreme
court of the united states
um it is not tied to my nomination to
the supreme court of the united
united states i have said repeatedly
under oath
that i had no conversations with anyone
in the white house about that case
and i'm not sure it to the extent
there's a suggestion that i have
an agenda that i want to strike down
people's protection for pre-existing
conditions that's just not true
um i've never taken that position and as
i've also said repeatedly
any policy preferences that i have don't
matter anyway they're irrelevant
so making that law coming out with the
contours of the aca that's your job
it is our job it is the job of policy
making
branches of government it's the job of
whatever combination of state and
federal lawmakers
and other policy makers have what a
judge is not a policy maker
when congress passes a law congress is
in charge of making sure that that law
works
insofar as that doesn't work or that law
ends up being stricken down it's our job
to replace it with something that does
work whether
uh constitutionally or otherwise in all
respects
that's our job not yours
you made some comments a few years ago
comments with which i wholeheartedly
agree
raising a criticism with chief justice
roberts
and his majority decision
in nfib versus sebelius decision and
don't worry i'm not going to ask you to
to weigh in on this you made those
comments at the time and
they're not relevant to me now but i set
this up for reasons i'll explain in a
moment
he rewrote the affordable care act not
just once but twice
in substantive ways in order to save
that law
from an otherwise inevitable finding of
unconstitutionality because that law as
written by this congress
was in fact unconstitutional into
material respects at issue in nfib
versus sebelius
blatantly unconstitutional he
effectively
acknowledged that the law as written
couldn't
pass constitutional muster and so he
rewrote it not just once but twice in
order to save it
that's water under the bridge that
happened it's
inexcusable that he did that he misused
the judicial authority
that case has absolutely nothing to do
with california versus texas it has
absolutely nothing to do with the
question of severability
in that case would it be fair to say
that my very strong opinions
uh that i've just expressed do not
indicate how i would feel
uh how i would lean were i a jurist
uh in california versus texas
um i think you're correct senator lee
that the question the legal issue
is entirely different in california
versus texas severability is its own
independent doctrine and has nothing to
do with the statutory interpretation
questions presented in sibelius
in many circumstances in this country we
see
emotionally charged issues that boil
and boil for a long time it can't always
be resolved not everybody's going to
agree on everything
not everybody is going to agree on
certain hot
button social issues that
result in some cases from just basic
differences
in how people view life and how people
view their place in the universe
one of those areas where it manifests
itself is in the area of abortion
people view life and when it begins
differently
some of that's informed by religious
beliefs some of it's
informed just by people's common sense
approach
to what they think the law ought to say
and what it ought not to say
disputes regarding when life begins and
disputes regarding
abortion didn't begin with roe versus
wade
what did change with roe versus wade
however was the federalization
and the grasping of the issue
and the taking it beyond the realm of
political debate
within the federal judiciary such that
elected lawmakers were no longer in a
position
to be the primary drivers of policy
as a result over the last few decades
you've had all kinds of questions that
have been put
into uncertainty you've got uncertainty
by
people at the state level who want to
make their own decisions
about certain things around abortion
they know they can't
prohibit it entirely they know that
there's this undue burden
standard that has to be addressed
nobody's completely sure in advance what
that means
and so they work around it there are
discussions that arise
regarding health and safety
qualifications for abortion clinics how
close an abortion clinic needs to be
to an accredited hospital how it needs
to be staffed
and what the sanitation protocols are
then you've got
more recently
some states passing laws saying look
there's abundant medical science
showing that an unborn human
can feel and respond to pain as early as
i don't know
10 or 12 gestational weeks but certainly
by 20 weeks
and so by 20 weeks we're going to adopt
a different set of legal procedures for
an abortion
as a result of that because if this is a
human that
everybody agrees can feel and respond to
pain we have to handle that differently
all of those things the legitimacy of
those laws
are thrown into the federal courts yet
again
all because those were made federal
issues
now i want to be very clear you'd have
the impression from watching debates
in circumstances like this one and
in protests outside the supreme court of
the united states you'd have the
impression
that if roe versus wade
didn't exist that all of a sudden
abortion would immediately become
illegal in every state
in america that assumes a lot of facts
not in evidence in fact
that assumes a lot of things contrary to
evidence
it is not the fact that
it is simply not the case that the fate
of health care in america turns on
whether or not someone is
confirmed to the supreme court of the
united states nor is it a fact
to suggest that the availability of an
abortion or lack thereof
is contingent upon anyone's confirmation
to the supreme court
of the united states the fact that we
have this debate and the fact that it's
become
as protracted as personal as ugly as it
has
could i i suspect be traced to the fact
that we've tried to take a debatable
matter
beyond debate and we've tried to take it
outside the political branches of
government
where people can elect their individual
representatives
and have laws respecting and reflecting
the views of their respective
communities
we're a country of what 330 million
americans it's really really difficult
to have those 330 million americans
reflected
in nine members of the supreme court
it's still really hard to have them
reflected in 100 senators and 435
representatives
that's doable especially when those
people are elected
they stand for election every couple
years in the case of the house every six
years in the case of the senate
it doesn't happen that way in the
supreme court of the united states
so to my colleagues on the other side of
the aisle who we're fear-mongering on
this
causing people to worry and lose sleep
over this fundraising over this
fundraising over threats that people are
going to lose their health care
fundraising over
threats that people are going to be
dying in the streets because the lack of
availability of this or that medical
procedure i'd ask have we created a
monster
have we ourselves through our own
inaction through our own voluntary
cessation of authority to a
non-legislative non-political branch
have we created the very
set of untenable social circumstances
that are causing people to protest
outside
of a non-political entity i think we
have to ask
ourselves that question from time to
time
life is in fact valuable it's not a
religious statement
to make that observation in fact it's
the foundation of basically all
of our laws not just in this country
not just in in countries with christian
origins
but in basically every country that has
ever existed
anywhere in the world a purpose of
government
is to protect life that's
what it's about if we can't agree
on the fact that it's reasonable that
people ought to be able to have some say
at least at some limit at least at some
point beyond the moment when
uh an unborn human can feel and respond
to pain
something's wrong with us and if we're
going to leave those things
perpetually in the hands of the
unelected
it might be really convenient for
political fundraising within congress
but it's not good for the united states
of america
it's not good for a constitutionally
limited government
it's not good for our individual
liberties
judge barrett alexander hamilton
was prescient in a number of areas he
had some crazy ideas
he did some crazy things he was also
freaking brilliant
i think he foresaw certain aspects of
our lives when he described
the differences between the branches of
government in federalist 78.
and in federalist 78 he said that
the legislative branch congress being a
political branch
a branch whose job it is to make policy
to make law
is possessed with will
and that what's possessed by the
judicial branch is not will
but judgment he then went on to explain
that
it's really important to maintain that
that clear distinction
between will and judgment unless you
have
a judicial branch consisting of people
who are not elected by the people not
accountable to the people at the regular
intervals
and who serve basically for the rest of
their lives so long as they're on good
behavior
you can't have them exercising will
because it's not their job what do you
think he meant what's the difference
between will and judgment
i think will is the imposition
of policy preferences as happens in the
making of
law um judgment
is evaluating that law for its
consistency with the constitution for
example
or to give another example to interpret
what that law means
but it most certainly is not the
imposition of policy preferences a judge
who approaches a case um as an
opportunity for an
exercise of will has acted
has betrayed her judicial duty
how does she know when she's reached
that point
um so i think
it requires disciplined judicial
decision making
so you approach the text you
treat it as a text you treat it as law
you know i've described originalism and
textualism so i won't belabor that point
but i will say that one practice that
i have um one check that i put on myself
to to make sure that i'm not biased is
that when i write an opinion
i try to read it from the perspective of
the losing party
so that any sympathy that i might feel
for the particular result that i reach
i try to make the sympathy run the other
way to see if it will still hold
and also to see like you know i would be
disappointed in this outcome if it was
my child
whose sentence or criminal conviction or
civil loss whatever it is is on the line
but would i still think it was a
well-reasoned opinion
and that's the test that i use for
myself
i think discipline is required um but i
take it very very seriously
as we've had this conversation today one
of the uh
one of the arguments that's been made by
some of my colleagues is referred to
activism
and has has uh accused
if i understood the argument correctly
uh some textualist
originalist jurists as having engaged in
activism now
i want to be clear i i i'm one who
doesn't believe that they're is
any thing worse about an activist judge
than a pacifist
judge meaning i think it's every bit as
bad
to be a pacifist
that is for example to let stand
an invalid unconstitutional law
as if it were valid and constitutional
it's every bit as bad to do that
as it is to invalidate as
unconstitutional something that is in
fact
not unconstitutional what do you you
agree with me that
both of those are equally in instances
of
bad judging they are both instances as
as you've posed them of not following
the law
not following the constitution or not
correctly uh interpreting a statute
by the same token a judge who
fails to grant a meritorious dispositive
motion
and a judge who grants a non-meritorious
dispositive motion
they've both probably done an equally
bad thing is that right
yeah does the constitution say anything
about the size of the supreme court um
the constitution does not
uh that is a question left open to
congress
it's my understanding that it's been
nine for about 150 years but that's as a
matter of statute
not constitutional requirement so it's
statutory
it's a statutory uh decision one that
stood for
more than a century and a half it's a
decision nonetheless that
uh has some bearing could have some
bearing on constitutional issues correct
um insofar as there would be more
decision-makers
on the court if if we abandoned
uh the long-standing historical practice
and tradition of having nine justices
could that have an
impact on the way the three branches of
government interact with each other
possibly but it's difficult for me to
imagine what specific
constitutional question you're asking
and of course there were one of course
of course there are
strong reasons i believe why over the
last
more than a century and a half we've
left that number at nine
uh as you point out there's nothing in
the constitution that requires it
we could come up with any number we
wanted there does have to be a supreme
court
and such inferior courts as we choose to
create
uh but it doesn't specify the number of
seats that can be on there
there are nonetheless good credential
reasons reasons
having to do with respect for the
separation of powers between the three
branches of government
reasons that have over the last 150 plus
years
left us to leave that number at nine
the last time as far as i can tell there
was any serious effort
to move the number above nine it was in
the fall of 1936 when president franklin
d roosevelt
got tired of this so-called four
horsemen of the apocalypse
a few members of the supreme court who
are consistently voting
against his agenda and sometimes joined
by one or more other members of the
supreme court
he got particularly tired of this and so
he proposed packing the court and let me
explain what i mean by packing the court
here what i
mean when i refer to this is increasing
the number of seats
on the supreme court and doing so
by statute with the intent of altering
the composition of the court
for short-term political gain
that's what fdr wanted to do
notwithstanding the fact that he had a
uh an overwhelming super majority
in both houses of congress fortunately
fdr's idea that he pushed in the fall
of 1936 didn't
make it anywhere it didn't gain progress
it met
enough opposition even with both houses
of congress being overwhelmingly
controlled by his political party
that it stalled quite mercifully
and it's remained ever since then at
nine justices i think it would have been
a colossal mistake joe biden himself as
a u.s senator is a member of this body
in a proceeding of this committee in
1983 gave a rousing speech that i
recommend to all
talking about that very thing
acknowledging that the constitution
doesn't require it but our respect
for the separation of powers really
ought to lead to us sticking to the
number nine
don't pack the court in recent days i've
seen some in the media
and some in this body try to redefine
what it means
to pack the court some have suggested
well
court packing takes various forms and it
can mean confirming a lot of people
uh uh all at once some have defined it
so as to suggest
that it consists of doing that which the
trump administration and the republican
senate have been doing over the last
three and a half years which is
filling vacancies as they have arisen
and
doing so with textualist originalist
judges
this may not be something that some like
but this is not court packing
court packing is itself manipulative
it's something
that has great danger to do immense
political and constitutional harm to our
system of government in part because it
would set up
a one-way ratchet once you create a
position and confirm someone to that
position
absent death retirement or impeachment
and removal
that position remains in place
so
if for example a future
congress and white house were to decide
to get together
and to pack the court and increase the
number say to 11.
and let's say it's democrats who do that
and we've got joe biden now as a
presidential candidate who's refusing to
say whether he would do it
there's a reason he's not saying whether
he would do it there's only one reason
why you refuse to answer that question
it's your if you're wanting to be able
to do it
but you don't want to take the heat for
the fact that you're thinking about
doing it right now
so if they do that where does it lead
well it inevitably leads to the point
where the next time republicans
have control of both houses of congress
and the white house they'd increase it
as well
you'd end up increasing it incrementally
before long it looks like the senate in
star wars where you've got hundreds of
people on there i don't know what the
whole
total number would be but you increase
it at all
you change the number at all you do so
for partisan political purposes at all
you delegitimize the court
and you can't delegitimize the court
without fundamentally threatening
and eroding and impairing some of our
most
valued liberties
you can't do that without inevitably
threatening things like
religious freedom things like free
speech
things that are themselves often
unpopular
but are protected by the constitution
precisely because they are unpopular
and yes in that respect the constitution
is sometimes counter-democratic
sometimes it can be described
as fundamentally undemocratic in fact
it's the whole
reason to have a constitution is to
protect us from the impulse
of a majority that might be bent on
harming
the few in the name of the many
that's why the law is so important
that's why the position
for which you're being considered is
so essential that's why we've got to do
our job
to make sure that the only people who
get the job for which you've been
nominated
fit the bill you judge barrett
or someone in whom i have immense
confidence
immense trust and i look forward to
voting
to confirming you for that very position
uh thank you senator lee uh we'll take
let's uh
come back at 12 45 we'll uh start with
uh senator whitehouse
we have 15 senators left everybody takes
the 30 minutes
seven and a half hours we'll take a
break for uh
for dinner tonight sometime later on in
a short break uh are you doing okay
three hours about right so we'll come
back at 12 45
and right now we're on schedule to be
here to nine o'clock but we'll do
whatever the committee wants
uh we're in recess to 12 45.
so
hang in there
thank you
yeah i thought that was very curious i
think her ascendant cancer made that
absolutely sense to me that when you
look at the history of
felonies and if it's not dangerous do
you
take someone's constitutional right away
which is to own a gun
and the idea of how do you vote and what
conditions are
placed on voting is done at the state
level not the federal level
and i feel very comfortable that she is
not antagonistic
to voting rights and that she took a
recent view of felonies in terms of
depriving the second amendment i've
always felt that
i think she got it right the bottom line
here is it's been very good hearing i
think
i think senators have asked her very
good questions quite frankly hard
questions
i think she's uh reported herself well
and uh we'll keep going
a little bit more i think she's done a
pretty marvelous job of explaining
textualism and originalism and how you
come to a different conclusion was
khalia
but she can't as ginsburg said tell you
how she may roll
can i think the president had a crowded
rally in florida last night maybe he
should have done that
in the middle of this tent i talked to
him last night he was uh
i felt like he needs to get out on the
campaign trail i know
uh vice president biden's app campaign i
think it's a big campaign yes sir
can i talk to you about you raise the
issue of your own election during the
middle east hearing is that appropriate
i think it's pretty appropriate for me
to respond to political attacks in a
political way
if you didn't catch it all day yesterday
was the tax on the aca
they mentioned three times south
carolina
what would happen if the aca is repealed
i thought it was fair for me to say
my position is there's a better way for
south carolina
so yes i think having a right to respond
to political
arguments politically and i wanted to
make sure the difference between
our political debate about the aca and
how it would be decided with corporal
support
thank y'all
is
okay
okay
sure
over there
okay
yes
is
oh
thank you
all right
i
he's right here
foreign
okay
only forgive me
foreign
hey
make a left
oh
thank you
so um
on the ground
oh
yes
uh
okay
this guy is
yes
um
i thought
crash
sitting here
lauren is sitting with like those bags
oh
yes
um
i would say
okay
sexy
um
foreign
never forget
all
yeah
this is
hi hello
i know
okay
recorded
he was out of the game
foreign
one
okay
uh
yes
i see
it was a um
uh
but
that's the like
hello
thank you
is
yeah yeah
yes
is
i
that's okay
have you spoken to the president since
the hearings began
but seriously
nice
um
okay
you
i'm ready when you are are we
live
senator whitehouse thank you chairman
judge barrett
you can take a bit of a
breather on your return to the committee
because what i want to do is go through
with the people who are
watching this now the
conversation that you and i had when
we spoke on the telephone you were
kind enough to hear out a presentation
that i made and um i intend to ask some
questions in that area
but it doesn't make sense to ask
questions if i haven't
the predicate particularly for uh
viewers
who are watching this so
i guess the reason that i want to do
this is because people who are
watching this um need to understand that
this
small hearing room and
the little tv box that you're looking at
um the little screen that you're looking
at are
a little bit like the uh frame of a
puppet theater
and if you only look at what's going on
in the puppet theater
you're not gonna understand the whole
story you're not going to understand
um the real dynamic of what is going on
here
and you're certainly not going to
understand forces outside of this room
who are
pulling strings and pushing sticks
and causing uh the puppet theater to
react
so first let me say why do i think
outside forces
are here pulling strings well part of it
is behavior
we have colleagues here who supported
you this nominee before there was a
nominee
that's a little unusual
um we have the political ram job that
we have already complained of driving
this process
through at breakneck speed in the middle
of a pandemic while the senate is closed
for safety reasons
and while we're doing nothing about the
coveted
epidemic around us we have
some very awkward 180s from colleagues
mr chairman you figure in this uh
our leader um said back when it was
garland versus uh gorsuch
that of course of course the american
people should have a say
in the court's direction of course of
course
said mitch mcconnell that's long gone
senator grassley said the american
people shouldn't be denied
a voice that's long gone
senator cruz said you don't do this in
an election year
that's long gone and our chairman made
his famous hold the tape promise
if an opening comes in the last year of
president trump's term
we'll wait till the next election
that's gone too so
there is a lot of hard to explain
hypocrisy and rush taking place right
now
and my experience around politics is
that when you find
hypocrisy in the daylight
look for power in the shadows
now people may say what does all this
matter this is a
political parlor game it's no big deal
well there's some pretty high stakes
here that we've been
talking about uh here on the on our side
and i'll tell you three of them right
here
roe versus wade obergefell
and the obamacare cases
here's the gop platform the republican
platform the platform
of my colleagues on the other side of
this aisle say that a republican
president will appoint judges who will
reverse
roe obergefell and the obamacare cases
if you have a family member with an
interest in
some autonomy over their body under roe
versus wade
the ability to have a marriage have
friends marry
have a niece or a daughter or a son
marry someone of their same sex they
have
you've got a stake and if you're one of
the millions and millions of americans
who depend on
the affordable care act you've got a
stake
it's not just the platform over and over
again let's start by talking about the
affordable care act
here's the president talking about
this litigation that we're gearing up
this nominee for
for november 10th
in this litigation he said we want to
terminate health care under obamacare
that is the president's statement so
when we
react to that don't act as if we're
making this stuff
up this is what president trump
said this is what your party platform
says reverse the obamacare
cases senator after senator including
many in this committee
filed briefs saying that the affordable
care act should be thrown
out by courts why is it surprising for
us to be concerned that you want this
nominee
to do what you want nominees to do
one quick stop on nfib sibelius because
a lot of this has to do with money
this is an interesting comparison
national federation of independent
businesses until it filed the nfib
versus sebelius case
had its biggest donation ever of twenty
one thousand dollars
the year that it went to work on the
affordable care act
ten wealthy donors gave 10
million dollars
somebody deserves a thank you
so let's go on to roe v wade
same thing
same thing
the president has said that reversing
roe v wade will happen
automatically because he's putting
pro-life
justices on the court why would we not
take him at his word
the republican party platform says it
will reverse
roe why would we not comment on that
and take you at your word senators here
including senator hawley have said i
will vote only for nominees
who acknowledge that roe v wade is
wrongly decided
and their pledge to vote for this
nominee do the math
that's a really simple equation to run
the republican brief in june medical
said roe should be overruled
so don't act surprised when we ask
questions about whether that's what
you're up to here
and finally out in the ad world that you
have spared yourself
wisely judge barrett uh the susan b
anthony foundation
is running advertisements right now
saying that you are set
you are set to give our pro-life country
the court
that it deserves there's the ad with the
voice over she's set
she's set
and then row
obamacare cases and obergefell gay
marriage
national organization for marriage the
big group that opposes
same-sex marriage says in this
proceeding
all our issues are at stake republican
platform says it wants to reverse
obergefell and
the republican brief filed in the case
said
same-sex relationships don't fall within
any constitutional protection
so when we say the stakes are high on
this it's because you've said the stakes
are high on this
you have said that's what you want to do
so how
are people going about doing it what is
the scheme here let me start with this
one
in all cases there's big anonymous money
behind various
lanes of activity one lane of activity
is through the conduit of the federalist
society
it's managed by a guy was managed by a
guy named leonard leo
and it's taken over the selection of
judicial nominees
how do we know that to be the case
because trump has said so
over and over again his white house
counsel
said so so we have an anonymously funded
group
controlling judicial selection run by
this guy leonard leo
then in another lane we have again
anonymous funders
running through something called the
judicial crisis network
which is run by carrie severino and it's
doing pr
and campaign ads for republican
judicial nominees it got
17 million single 17 million dollar
donation
in the garland gorsuch contest it got
another single 17 million
donation to support kavanaugh somebody
perhaps the same person spent 35 million
dollars
to influence the makeup of the united
states supreme court tell me that's good
and then over here you have a whole
array of legal groups
also funded by dark money which have a
different role
they bring cases to the court they don't
wind their way to the court your honor
they get
shoved to the court by these legal
groups many of which ask to lose below
so they can get quickly to the court
to get their business done there
and then they turn up in a chorus an
orchestrated chorus of any key now i've
had a chance to have a look
at this and i was in a case actually as
an amicus myself
the consumer financial protection board
case
and in that case there were one two
three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven amicus
briefs filed and every single one of
them was
a group funded by something called
donors trust
donors trust is a gigantic identity
scrubbing device for the right wing
so that it says donor's trust is the
donor without whoever the real donor is
it doesn't have a business it doesn't
have a business plan it doesn't do
anything it's just
an identity scrubber
and this group here the bradley
foundation
funded eight out of the 11 briefs that
seems weird to me when you have
amicus briefs coming in little flotillas
that are funded by the same groups but
nominally separate in the court so
actually attach this
to my brief as an appendix
senator from center for media and
democracy saw it and they did better
work
they went on to say
which foundations funded the brief
writers in that
cfpb case here's the bradley foundation
for 5.6 million to those groups
here's donors trust 23 million
to those brief writing groups the grand
total across all the donor groups was 68
million dollars
to the groups that were filing amicus
briefs pretending that they were
different groups
and it's not just in the consumer
financial protection board
case you might say well that was just a
one-off here's janus the anti-labor case
that had a long trail through the court
through friedrichs and through knox and
through other decisions
and source watch and propublica did some
work about
this here's donor's trust and donors
capital fund
and here's the bradley foundation and
they totaled giving 45 million dollars
to the one two three four five six seven
8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 groups that filed amicus briefs
pretending to be different groups
and both of the lawyer groups in the
case
funded by donors trust funded by bradley
foundation in
janus this is happening over and over
and over again
and it goes beyond just the
briefs it goes beyond just the amicus
presentations
the federalist society remember this
group
that is acting as the conduit and that
donald trump has said is doing his
judicial selection
they're getting money from the same
foundations
from donors trust 16 16.7 million
dollars
from the bradley foundation 1.37 million
dollars
from the same group of foundations total
33 million dollars so you can start to
look
at these and you can start to
tie them together
the legal groups all the same funders
over and over again
bringing the cases and providing this
orchestrated
orchestrated chorus of amiki
then the same group also funds the
federalist society over here
the washington post wrote a big expose
about this and that made leonard leo a
little hot a little bit like a burned
agent
so he had to jump out and he went off to
go and do anonymously funded voter
suppression work
guess who jumped in to take over the
selection process in this case for judge
barrett
harry severino made the hop so once
again
ties right in together
so center for media and democracy has
done a little bit more research
here's a bradley foundation memo that
they've published
the bradley foundation is reviewing a
grant application
asking for money for this orchestrated
amicus
process and what do they say in the
staff recommendation it is important to
orchestrate their word not mine
important to orchestrate high caliber
amicus
efforts uh before the court they also
note that bradley has
done previous philanthropic investments
in the actual underlying legal actions
so bradley is funding
what do they call philanthropically
investing in
the underlying legal action and then
giving money to groups
to show up in the orchestrated chorus
of emiki that can't be good
and it goes on because they also found
this email this email
comes from an individual at the bradley
foundation
and it asks our friend leonard leo who
used to run the selection process
is there a 501c3 nonprofit to which
bradley could direct any support
of the two supreme court amicus projects
other than donors trust i don't know why
they wanted to avoid the
reliable identity scrubber donors trust
but for some reason they did
so leonard leo writes back on federalist
society address
so don't tell me that isn't federal
society business
on federalist society
on his address he writes back yes send
it to the judicial
education project which could take and
allocate the money
and guess who works for the judicial
education project
carrie severino who also helped select
this nominee running the trump
federalist society selection process
so the connections
abound in the washington post article
they point out that the judicial crisis
network's
office is on the same hallway in the
same building as the federalist society
and when they sent their reporter to
talk to somebody at the official crisis
network
somebody from the federalist society
came down to let them up
this more and more looks
like it's not three schemes
but it's one scheme with the same
funders
selecting judges funding campaigns for
the judges
and then showing up in court in these
orchestrated amicus flotillas
to tell the judges what to do
on the judicial crisis network you've
got the leonard leo connection obviously
she hopped in to take over for him
with the federalist society you've got
the campaigns that i've talked about
where they take 17 million contributions
that's a big check to write 17 million
dollars
to campaign for supreme court nominees
no idea who that is or what they got for
it
you've got briefs that she wrote
the republican senators filed briefs in
that nfib
case signed by ms severino
the woman who helped choose this nominee
has written briefs for republican
senators attacking the aca
don't say the hcas not an issue here and
by the way the judicial crisis network
funds
the republican attorneys general it
funds raga the republican attorney
general's association
and it funds individual republican
attorneys general and guess who the
plaintiffs are
in the affordable care act case
republican attorneys general
trump joined them because he didn't want
to defend so he's in
with the republican attorneys general
but here's the judicial crisis
network campaigning for supreme court
nominees writing briefs
for senators against the affordable care
act supporting the republicans who are
bringing this
case and leading this election process
for this
nominee here's the page off the brief
here's where they are mitch mcconnell
and on through the list senator collins
senator cornyn senator
hoeven senator who's still here
marco rubio it's a huge
assortment of republican senators who
carry severino wrote a beef for
against against against the affordable
care act
so this is a to me
pretty big deal i've never seen this
around any court that i've ever been
involved with where there's this much
dark money
and this much influence being used
here's how the washington post summed it
up this is a conservative activist
behind the scenes campaign to remake the
nation's courts
and it's a 250 million dollar
dark money operation 250 million dollars
is a lot of money to spend if you're not
getting anything for it
so that raises the question what are
they getting for it
well i showed the slide earlier on the
affordable care act
and on obergefell and on roe versus wade
that's where they lost but with another
judge
that could change that's where the
contest is
that's where the republican party
platform tells us to look
at how they want judges to rule to
reverse row
to reverse the obamacare cases and to
reverse obergefell and take away gay
marriage that is their
stated objective and plan why not take
them at their word
but there's another piece of it and that
is
not what's ahead of us but what's behind
us
what's behind us is now 80 cases mr
chairman
80 cases under chief justice roberts
that have these characteristics one they
were decided five to four
by a bare majority two
the five to four majority was partisan
in the sense that not one democrat
democratic appointee joined the five
i refer to that group as the roberts
five it changes a little bit
as with justice scalia's death for
instance
but there's been a steady roberts five
that has delivered
now 80 of these decisions and the last
characteristic of them is that there is
an identifiable republican donor
interest in those cases
and in every single case that donor
interest
won it was an 80 to zero
five to four partisan route
ransacking and it's important to look at
where those cases went because they're
not about
big public issues like getting rid of
the affordable care act
undoing roe versus wade and undoing
same-sex marriage they're about power
and if you look at those 80 decisions
they fall into four
categories over and over and over again
one
unlimited and dark money in politics
citizens united is the famous one but
it's continued sense with mccutchen and
we've got one coming up now
always the five for unlimited money in
politics
never protecting against dark money and
politics despite the fact that they said
it was going to be
transparent and who wins
when you allow unlimited dark money in
politics a very small group
the ones who have unlimited money to
spend and a motive to spend it in
politics
they win everybody else loses and if
you're looking
at who might be behind this let's talk
about people with unlimited money to
spend
and a motive to do it we'll see how that
goes
next knock the civil jury down
whittle it down to a nub the civil jury
was in the constitution
in the bill of rights in our darn
declaration of independence
but it's annoying to big corporate
powers
because you can swagger your way as a
big corporate power through congress
you can go and tell the president you
put money into to elect what to do
he'll put your stooges at the epa it's
all
great until you get to the civil jury
because they have an obligation as you
know judge barrett they have an
obligation under the law to be fair to
both parties irrespective of their size
you can't bribe them you're not allowed
to it's a crime
to tamper with the jury it's standard
practice to tamper with congress and
they make decisions based on the law
if you're used to being the boss and
swaggering your way around the political
side
you don't want to be answerable before a
jury and so
one after another these 85 to 4
decisions
have knocked down whittled away at the
civil jury a great american institution
third first was unlimited dark money
second was demean and diminish the civil
jury
third is weaken regulatory agencies
a lot of this money i'm convinced is
polluter money
the koch industries is a polluter the
fossil fuel industry is a polluter
who else would be putting buckets of
money into this and wanting to hide who
they are behind donors trust or other
schemes
and what if if you're a big polluter
what do you want you want
weak regulatory agencies you want ones
that you can
box up and run over to congress and get
your friends to fix things for you in
congress
over and over and over again these
decisions are targeted at regulatory
agencies
to weaken their independence and weaken
their strength
and if you're a big polluter a weak
regulatory agency is your idea
of a good day and the last thing is in
politics
in voting why on earth
the court made the decision a factual
decision
not something appellate courts
ordinarily supposed to make as i
understand it
judge barrett the factual decision that
nobody needed to worry
about minority voters in pre-clearance
states
being discriminated against or that
legislators would try to knock back
their ability to vote
these five made that finding in shelby
county
against bipartisan legislation from both
houses of congress
hugely passed on no factual record
they just decided that that was a
problem that was over
on no record with no basis because
it got them to the result
that we then saw what followed state
after state after state
passed voter suppression laws one
so badly targeting african americans
that two courts said it was
surgically surgically tailored
to get after minority voters and
gerrymandering the other great
control bulk gerrymandering where you go
into a state
like the red map project did in ohio and
pennsylvania
and you pack democrats so tightly into a
few districts
that all the others become republican
majority districts
and in those states you send a
delegation to congress
that has a huge majority of republican
members
like 13 to 5 as i recall
in a state where the five the party of
the five
actually won the popular vote
you've sent a delegation to congress
that is out of step
with the popular vote of that state and
court after court figured out how to
solve that and the supreme court said
nope
five to four again nope we're not going
to take an interest in that question
in all these areas where it's about
political power
for big special interests and people who
want to fund campaigns
and people who want to get their way
through politics without actually
showing up
doing it behind donors trust in other
groups doing it through these schemes
over and over and over again you see the
same thing
80 decisions judge barrett 80 decisions
and 80 to zero sweep
i don't i don't think you've tried cases
but some cases
the issue is bias and discrimination and
if you're making a bias case
as a trial lawyer lindsey graham is a
hell of a good trial lawyer if he wanted
to make a bias case
dick durbin is a hell of a good trial
lawyer if they wanted to make a bias
case
and they could show an 80 to 0 pattern
a that's admissible and b i'd love to
make that argument to the jury
i'd be really hard-pressed to be the
lawyer saying no 80 to zero it's just a
bunch of flukes
all five four all partisan all this way
so something is not right
around the court and dark money has a
lot
to do with it special interests have a
lot to do with it
donors trust and whoever's hiding behind
donor's trust
has a lot to do with it and the bradley
foundation
orchestrating its emmy key over at the
court
has a lot to do with it
so i thank you judge barrett for
listening to me now a
second time and uh i think this gives
you a chance
um for you and i to tee up an
interesting conversation tomorrow
and i thank my colleagues for hearing me
out thank you senator whitehouse
uh senator cruz
oh mr chairman can i put three letters
in you know without a judge thank you
thank you mr chairman judge barrett
welcome
uh congratulations on being nominated
uh congratulations on enduring
the confirmation proceedings
and i think it is a particularly good
thing we've made it through
what i guess you would call the top of
the lineup of the questioning
and some of the smartest and and frankly
most effective questioners
on the democratic side and i think it
speaks volumes
that collectively they've had very few
questions for you
most effective and
virtually none uh calling into question
your credentials which are impeccable
didn't make the cuts
uh your record uh
and what i think is
has been an extraordinary life you've
led so that
uh that should be the source of of
great satisfaction in terms of the
scholarly record judicial record that
you've spent a lifetime building
i want to start by asking you a question
why is
the first amendment's protection of
religious liberty why is that important
well i think it's broadly viewed that
the
framers uh protected and ratifiers
protected the free exercise of religion
because
you know for reasons that we all know
from history of persecuted religious
minorities fleeing to the united states
that enshrining that protection um you
know
it was one of the bill of rights because
it was considered so fundamental
and why why does that matter to
americans what difference does
that make in in anybody's life well i
think all of the bill of rights each and
every one of them
is important to americans because we
value the constitution
um including religious liberty
how about the free speech protections of
the first amendment why why are those
important
so that minority viewpoints can't be
squashed
so that it's not just the majority that
can speak popular views you
you know i you don't really need the
first amendment if what you're saying is
something that everybody wants to hear
you need it when people are trying to
silence you
and how about the second amendment why
is the right to keep and bear arms
important
well you know we talked about heller
earlier this morning
and you know what heller tells us is
that the second amendment
protects an individual right to bear
arms um for self-defense
well i think all of those rights and i
agree with you the entire bill of rights
uh is incredibly important to americans
i also think what is really striking
about this hearing
today and also yesterday is that senate
democrats
are not defending what i think is really
a
radical agenda that they have when it
comes to the bill of rights
and the topics they're discussing today
have little bearing
to the rights that are really at
issue and in jeopardy of the supreme
court
and so let's take a few minutes to to go
through them
first of all we've had some discussion
of roe versus way
you have declined to give an opinion on
a matter that might be pending before
the court
that is of course the same answer that
every single sitting justice has given
when he or she was sitting in the same
chair you are
it is mandated by the judicial cannons
of ethics
whether one is a nominee of a democratic
president or republican president that
has been the answer
that has been given to this committee
for decades
but i do think it is interesting that
our democratic colleagues number one
don't discuss what would actually happen
if there came a day in which roe vs wade
were overruled
which is namely that it would not
suddenly become the case that
abortion was illegal but rather it would
revert
to the status of the law as it's been
for
nearly 200 years of our nation's history
which is that the question
uh of the permissibility of abortion is
a question for elected legislatures at
the state levels
and at the federal level and
it is difficult to dispute that there
are a great many jurisdictions including
jurisdictions like california and new
york who even if roe versus wade
were no longer the law of the land their
elected legislatures would almost
certainly
continue unrestricted access to abortion
with
virtually no limitations
what i find interesting though is that
our democratic colleagues do not discuss
what is really the radical position
of the most liberal justices on the
supreme court
which is that no restrictions whatsoever
are permissible
when it comes to abortion yesterday one
of the
democratic senators made reference to
the case gonzales versus carhartt
um i'm quite familiar with that case and
i represented texas and a number of
other states as amiki in that case that
case concerned the constitutionality of
the federal ban on partial birth
abortion
that was legislation that passed
congress was signed into law that made
the really gruesome practice of partial
birth abortion illegal
overwhelming majority of americans
believe partial birth abortion should be
prohibited even those who
identify as pro-choice a significant
percentage of americans don't want to
see
that gruesome practice allowed
supreme court by a vote of five to four
in carhartt versus gonzales upheld the
federal ban on partial birth abortion
that means there were four justices
ready to strike it down
ready to conclude that you can't ban
partial birth abortion that you can't
ban late term abortion
and by the way other restrictions that
are at question
include parental consent laws parallel
notification laws
none of our democratic colleagues want
to talk about the justices they want to
see on the court would strike down
every single reasonable restriction
on unlimited abortion on demand that the
vast majority of americans support
how about free speech
well we've heard quite a bit about free
speech the senator from rhode island
just gave
a long presentation complete with lots
of charts
i'll say a couple of things on free
speech
first of all our democratic colleagues
when they address the issue of
so-called dark money and campaign
finance contributions
are often deeply deeply hypocritical
and don't address the actual facts that
exist
here are some facts
of the top 20 organizations spending
money for political speech in the year
2016
14 of them gave virtually all of their
money to democrats
and another three split their money
evenly so only three of the top 20 gave
money to republicans what did that mean
in practice that meant the top 20 super
pac donors contributed 422 million
dollars to democrats and 189 million to
republicans
those who give these impassioned
speeches against dark money don't
mention
that their side is funded by dark money
with a massive differential the senator
from rhode island talked about
big corporate powers
without acknowledging that the
contributions from the fortune 500 in
this presidential election
overwhelmingly favor joe biden and the
democrats
without acknowledging that the
contributions from wall street in this
election
overwhelmingly favor joe biden and the
democrats
it's an awful lot of rhetoric about
power
but it gets even more interesting when
you look at
supreme court nominations we just heard
an attack on the federalist society a
group that i've been a member of for
over 25
years i joined as a law student it's a
group that brings conservatives
libertarians constitutionalists together
to have robust discussions about the
constitution about the law
what's interesting
is nowhere in the senate of rhode
island's remarks was any reference
to a company called arabella advisors
which is a for-profit entity that
manages non-profits including
the 1630 fund in the new venture fund
now what on earth are those those sound
like
awfully dark and confusing names well
according to the wall street journal
this sunday
in the year 2017 and 2018 those entities
reported
987.5
million dollars in revenue
that's nearly a billion dollars
we heard a lot of thundering indignation
at what was described as 250 million
dollars of expenditures in this case
you've got a
billion dollars the senator rhode island
said
that much money much of which is dark
money that we don't know who contributed
it
he asked what are they getting for it
and by the way one of the things they're
getting for it is a group called demand
justice
a project of those entities
spent five million dollars opposing
justice brett kavanaugh and has just
launched a seven-figure ad buy
opposing your con confirmation
so all of the great umbrage about
the corporate interest or spending dark
money
is wildly in conflict
with the actual facts that the corporate
interests that are spending dark money
are funding the democrats
by a factor of three to one or greater
a fact that doesn't ever seem to be
acknowledged
but not only that
what was citizens united about it's
interesting most people at home they've
heard about citizens united they know it
makes democrats very very upset
but they don't actually know what the
case is about citizens united concerned
whether or not it was legal to make a
movie
criticizing a politician specifically
citizens united is a small non-profit
organization based here in dc
that made a movie that was critical of
hillary clinton
and the obama justice department took
the position that it could
fine it could punish citizens united
for daring to make a movie critical of a
politician
the case went all the way to the u.s
supreme court at the oral argument
there was a moment that was truly
chilling
justice sam alito asked the obama
justice department
is it your position under your theory of
the case
that the federal government can ban
books
and the obama justice department
responded yes
yes it is our position that if the books
criticize
a political candidate a politician the
federal government can
ban books
as far as i'm concerned that is a
terrifying view
of the first amendment citizens united
was decided five to four
by a narrow 5-4 majority the supreme
court concluded the first amendment did
not allow the federal government to
punish you
for making a movie critical of a
politician
and likewise that the federal government
couldn't ban books
four justices dissented four justices
were willing to say the federal
government can
ban books and kanban movies and
presumably
could ban books as well
when hillary clinton was running for
president she explicitly promised every
justice she nominated to the court
would pledge to overturn citizens united
by the way hillary clinton said she
would demand of her nominee something
you have rightly said
that this administration has not
demanded of you which is a commitment on
any case as to how you will rule
democrats have shown no compunction in
expecting their nominees to make a
promise here's how i'm going to vote
on a pending case judicial judicial
ethics be damned
or how about the second amendment
we've heard some reference to the heller
decision
senator from connecticut yesterday
talked about reasonable gun control and
gun safety provisions
well that of course was not what was at
stake
in the heller decision number one
majority decision in heller
justice scalia's opinion acknowledges
reasonable provisions things like
prohibitions on felons and possession
are permissible your opinion in the
cantor decision likewise acknowledged
that restrictions preventing dangerous
criminals from receiving firearms are
entirely consistent and permissible
under the second amendment
but the issue at heller was much more
fundamental
it was whether the second amendment
protects an individual right to keep and
bear arms at all
the vote in heller was five to four by a
vote of five to four the majority struck
down the district of columbia's total
prohibitions
on owning an operative firearm in the
district of columbia
the argument of the four dissenters was
not what our democratic colleagues talk
about here it wasn't
some reasonable gun control provisions
are okay that was not the argument of
the dissenters
that question we can actually have a
reasonable debate on reasonable minds
can differ on what the appropriate line
should be what are reasonable laws there
but that was not what was at issue at
heller
the position of the four dissenters was
the second amendment protects no
individual right to keep and bear arms
whatsoever
but merely a quote collective right of
the militia
which is fancy lawyer talk for a
non-existent right
four justices
would have ruled that way one vote away
the consequences of the court concluding
that there is no individual right under
the first amendment
would mean you and i and every american
watching this
would lose your second amendment right
it would mean the federal government the
state government the city
could ban guns entirely could make it a
criminal offense
for any one of us to own a firearm
and no individual american would have
any judicially cognizable right to
challenge that
that is a radical reading
of the constitution that is effectively
erasing
the second amendment from the bill of
rights
and hillary clinton likewise promised in
2016 that every justice she nominated
would commit to voting to turn heller
they were big on litmus tests
and joe biden although he refuses to
answer just about anything
about whether or not he's going to pack
the court he did tell the american
people the voters don't deserve to know
whether he's going to pack the court
truly a statement
of disrespect and contempt for the
voters
unusual
in our political process
one vote away from the second amendment
being erased from the bill of rights
none of our democratic colleagues admit
that that is their agenda and yet those
are the justices
that democratic presidential nominees
are promising they will appoint
justices who will take away your right
to criticize politicians justices
who will allow censorship justices who
will allow movies and books
to be banned justices who will erase the
second amendment from the bill of rights
and how about religious liberty
religious liberty is an issue
near and dear to a great many of us
the right of every american to live
according to your faith according to
your conscience whatever that faith
may be
religious liberty is fundamentally about
diversity it's about respecting
diversity that whatever your faith
tradition
might be the government is not going to
trample on it
religious liberty cases over and over
again have been decided 5
4 the case of ann orton versus perry a
case i litigated
dealt with the ten commandments monument
that stands on the state capitol grounds
has been there since 1961 in texas
an individual plaintiff an atheist a
homeless man filed a lawsuit seeking to
tear down the ten commandments the case
went all the way to the u.s supreme
court it was decided five to four
four justices were willing to say in
effect send in the bulldozers and tear
down that monument
because you can't gaze on the image of
the ten commandments on public lands
another case the mojave desert veterans
memorial
this is a memorial erected to the men
and women who gave their lives in world
war one
to lone white latin cross simple and
bare in the middle of the desert i've
been there
on sunrise rock where it stands
the aclu filed a lawsuit saying you
cannot gaze on the image
of a cross on public land and the aclu
won in the district court they won in
the ninth circuit court of appeals the
federal courts
ordered that veterans memorial to be
covered up with a burlap sack
with a chain on the bottom and then a
plywood box
when the case went to the u.s supreme
court
i represented 3 million veterans pro
bono for free
defending that veterans memorial
we won 5-4 and there were four
justices prepared to say tear down the
veterans memorial
and under the reasoning that they put
forth
they were not far away from saying bring
out the chisels
and remove the crosses and the stars of
david
on the tombstones of the men and women
that gave their lives at arlington
cemetery defending this nation
that is a radical view and we're one
vote away
that is utterly contrary
to the text of the first amendment to
the understanding of the first amendment
when we argued the ten commandments case
in the u.s supreme court
there was more than a little bit of
irony
and that do you know how many times the
image of the ten commandments appears
in the courtroom of the supreme court
the answer to that is 43.
there are two images of the ten
commandments carved on the wooden doors
as you walk out of the courtroom you
will soon be sitting looking at them
there are forty images of the ten
commandments
on the bronze gates on this both sides
of the courtroom
and then judge barrett when you're
sitting at the bench above your left
shoulder will be a freeze you know well
a freeze carved into the wall of great
law givers one of whom is moses
he is standing there holding the ten
commandments
the text of which is legible in hebrew
as he looks down upon the justices and
four justices
were willing to say in effect bring out
the sandblasters
because we must remove god from the
public square
that is a profound threat to our
religious liberty and i would note that
it doesn't just extend to public
acknowledgements
it also extends
to religious liberty the little sisters
of the poor
our catholic convent of nuns who take
oaths of poverty
who devote their lives to caring for the
sick
caring for the needy caring for the
elderly
the obama administration litigate
litigated against the little sisters of
the poor
seeking to find them in order to
force them to pay for abortion inducing
drugs among others
it's truly a stunning situation when you
have the federal government litigating
against
nuns
the supreme court decided the hobby
lobby case another case routinely
denounced
by senate democrats the hobby lobby case
concluded that the federal government
could not permissibly
force a christian business to violate
their faith it reflected the religious
liberty traditions of our country that
you can live according to your faith
without the government trampling on it
you know what this body did i'm sorry to
say
senate democrats introduced legislation
to gut the religious freedom restoration
act religious freedom restoration act
when it passed this body
passed with an overwhelming bipartisan
majority
senate democrats including chuck schumer
and joe biden and ted kennedy all voted
for the religious freedom restoration
act
democratic president bill clinton signed
the religious freedom restoration act
and yet in the wake of the hobby lobby
decision this body voted on legislation
to just
gut the protections for religious
liberty
and i'm sorry to say every single senate
democrat voted to do so not a
single one zero
would defend religious liberty
joe biden has already pledged if he is
elected he plans to initiate again
the attack on the little sisters of the
poor
you know it's interesting folks in the
press like to talk about pope francis
and on some issues pope francis has been
vocal when it comes to the environment
when it comes to issues concerning
immigration the pope has been vocal on
issues that our democratic colleagues
like and agree with the press is happy
to amplify those views
somehow missing from that amplification
is acknowledgment that when the pope
came to the united states in washington
he went and visited the little sisters
of the poor
here in dc he went to their home here in
dc and the vatican explained
he did so because he wanted to highlight
their cause
that the federal government shouldn't be
persecuting
nuns for living according to their faith
that's what's at stake in these
nominations
and you won't hear any of that from the
senate democrats on this committee
that's why their base is so angry
at your nomination judge barrett because
they don't believe you are going to join
the radical efforts
to erase those fundamental rights from
the bill of rights
i believe that issue preserving the
constitution preserving the bill of
rights our fundamental liberties
i believe is the most important issue
facing the country in the november
elections
and i think for those of us who value
those rights
we should take solace in the fact that
not a single democrat
is willing even to acknowledge
the radical sweep of their agenda much
less defendant
they know it's wildly unpopular and look
right at the heart of this
is a decision many democrats have made
to abandon democracy
you see most policies policies like
obamacare policies like health care
most policies under our constitutional
system are meant to be decided by
democratically
elected legislatures why so they can be
accountable to the people
so if the voter voters disagree
they can throw the bums out but too many
democrats have decided today
that democracy is too complicated it's
too hard to actually convince
your fellow americans of the merits of
your position it's much easier
just to give it to the courts find
five lawyers in black robes and let them
decree the policy outcome you want
which makes your radical base happy
presumably makes
the millions if not billions in dark
money being spent for democrats happy
without actually having to justify it to
the american people
judge barrett i'm not going to ask you
to respond to any of that
but i do want to shift to a different
topic
which is a bit more about you personally
your background
judge bear do you speak any foreign
languages
once upon a time i could speak french
but i have fallen woefully out of
practice so please don't ask me to do
that right now
uh you can be assured of that because my
uh i had two years of high school french
and and and i suspect yours remains much
better than mine
um how about music do you play any
instruments
the piano do you how long have you
played the piano
well i played the piano growing up for
10 years
and now most of my piano playing
consists of playing my children's songs
for them and supervising
their own piano practice i look forward
one day when i have more time to be able
to
choose some of my own music now do the
kids
do piano lessons as well the kids do
piano lessons some of the older ones who
are in high school have gotten
so busy with sports and those things
that they've stopped but the younger
children do
our girls are 9 and 12 and we have they
both do piano lessons and i will say at
least in our household it is
less than voluntary
i you know one of the things heidi and i
found
particularly the last six months during
covid which has been an extraordinary
crisis
is just with two kids at home that doing
distance learning when schools were shut
down was really hard for us with two
children
for you and your husband you've got
seven kids how did uh
how did y'all manage through the
lockdowns and distance learning what was
that like in in the barrett household
well it was a challenging time as it was
for every american
um our oldest daughter emma who's in
college moved home
at that point because uh she's at notre
dame it closed so emma obviously could
manage her own e-learning and our high
school
age uh children test and vivian could
too but jesse and i just tried to take a
divide and conquer approach for
the younger four and yeah it was quite
challenging i assure you
one part of your story that i find
particularly remarkable
and that i admire
is the decision you made to adopt two
children you and your husband had
five biological children you adopted two
more
both of your adopted children are from
haiti
haiti is a country that has some of the
most crushing poverty in the world
my brother-in-law is a missionary in
haiti
and actually heidi and the girls just
got back from haiti a couple of weeks
ago
um i was curious if he would share
with this committee and with the
american people uh
what led you and your husband to make
the decision to adopt it's it's i think
one of the most loving
and compassionate decisions any family
can make
when jesse and i were engaged we met
another couple
who had adopted in this instance it was
a couple who had adopted a child with
special needs
and then we also met another couple who
had adopted a few children
internationally
and we decided at that point while we
were engaged that at some point in the
future
we wanted to do that ourselves um and i
guess we had imagined initially that we
would
have whatever biological kids that we
had decided to have
and then adopt at the end but after we
had our first daughter
emma we thought well why wait so i was
expecting tess um when we went
and got vivian so she and test function
we call them our fraternal twins they're
in the same grade
and it really has enriched our family um
immeasurably
and you know once we had adopted vivian
at that point then we made the decision
that we definitely wanted to adopt again
and so several years later john peter
entered our family
so your children have been wonderfully
well behaved
i think you're an amazing role model for
little girls
what advice would you give little girls
well what i'm saying is not designed
my brother now has left i was just
thinking of what my dad told me before
the spelling bee about anything boys can
do girls can do better
and since um my sons are sitting behind
me i'll also say
but boys are great too thank you
thank you senator klobuchar thank you
very much
mr chair welcome again judge
since i have the draw to always follow
senator cruz i did want to make one
thing clear
after listening to that for a half hour
that joe biden
is catholic and he is a man of faith
and then i want to turn to something
else and that is that
we need a reset here in my mind for the
people at home a bit of a reality
check uh that this isn't normal
right now uh we have to understand that
what people are dealing with that 7.7
million people have gotten this virus
the 214 000 americans have died
and for people watching at home and
wondering what we're all doing in this
room right now and maybe you're home
because you lost your job or
maybe you got your kids crawling all
over your couch right now
maybe you're trying to teach your first
grader how to do a mute button to go to
school
um or maybe you've got a small business
that
you had to close down or that's
struggling we should be doing something
else right now
we shouldn't be doing this we should be
passing coronavirus relief like the
house just did
which was a significant bill that would
have been a big help and i think people
have to know that
right now and whether you're democrat
independent or republican and that's why
i started out yesterday by telling
people
that they need to vote number two
some of my colleagues throughout this
hearing on the other side
have been kind of portraying the job
that the judge is before us on
as being some kind of ivory tower
exercise
i think one of my friends called it uh
related that you'd be dealing with the
dormant commerce clause well i'm sure
that might be true
but we also know that this is the
highest court in the land that the
decisions of this court
have a real impact on people and i
appreciate a judge that you said that
you didn't want to be a queen
i actually wouldn't mind being a queen
around here the truth be known i
wouldn't mind doing it
kind of a benevolent queen and making
decisions so we could get things done
um but uh you said you wouldn't let your
views influence you
and the like but the truth is the
supreme court rulings
they rule people's life they decide if
people can get married
they decide what schools they can go to
they decide if they could even have
access to contraception all of these
things
matter so i want to make that clear and
the third
reset here that i think we need to have
is that this hearing is not normal
it is a sham it is a rush
to put in a justice the last time that
we had
a vacancy so close to an election
was when abraham lincoln was president
and he made the wise decision to wait
until after the election the last time
we lost a justice
so close to an election that's what he
did
today we are 21 days from the election
people are voting millions of people
have already cast their ballots and i go
to the words of senator mcconnell the
last time we had a situation in election
year he said
the american people should have a voice
in the selection of their next supreme
court justice
therefore this vacancy should not be
filled until we have a new president
that set the precedent that so many of
you
have embraced or at least you did a few
years ago and that is that in an
election year
the people choose the president and then
the president nominates
the justice so why is this happening
well that's a good question um
this guy our president he is the one
that decided to plop a supreme court
nomination in the middle of an election
when people's health care is on the line
with the case before
the court on november 10th so let's see
what he said
about the supreme court well one of
president
trump's campaign promises
in 2015 was that his judicial
appointment will do the right thing
on obamacare you can see it right here
and in fact judge just one day after you
were nominated this is like
a few weeks ago he said also on twitter
that it would be a big win
if the supreme court strikes down
the health law so judge my first
question do you think we should take the
president at his word
when he says his nominee will do the
right thing and overturn the affordable
care act
senator klobuchar um i
can't really speak to what the president
has said on twitter
um he hasn't said any of that to me and
what i can tell you
um as i have told your colleagues
earlier today
is that no one has elicited from me any
commitment in a case or even brought up
a commitment in the case
i am 100 committed to judicial
independence from political pressure
so whatever people's you know party
platforms
maybe or campaign promises maybe the
reason why judges have life tenure
is to insulate them from those pressures
so i take my oath seriously to follow
the law
and you know i have not pre-committed
nor would i pre-commit to decide a case
any particular way okay
and i think this life temnier this idea
that you have just for everyone out
there a job for life
makes this even more important for us to
consider
where you might be and i know you have
not said how you would re
rule on this case uh that's coming up
right after the election
uh where the president had said it would
be a big win if the supreme court
strikes down the law
but you have directly criticized justice
roberts in
an article in my own state in one of the
minnesota law school
journals it was in 2017 it was the same
year you became a judge
and when roberts writes the opinion to
uphold the
affordable care act you said he quote
pushed the affordable care act beyond
its plausible meaning
to save the statute is that correct
senator klobuchar i just want to clarify
is this the constitutional commentary
publication that you and i discussed yes
it is but it's still a minnesota
university of minnesota yes okay i
just wanted to be sure because yeah i
hadn't published to them and i just
again did you ask that question did you
say that that he
pushed the affordable care act beyond
its plausible meaning to save the
statute
um one thing i want to clarify is you
said that i
criticized you know chief justice
roberts
and i don't attack people just ideas so
that was just designed to
to make a comment about his reasoning in
that case which i've as i've said before
is consistent with the way the majority
opinion characterized it
as the less plausible reading of the
statute okay so you didn't agree with
his reasoning in the case that upheld
the affordable care act
what i said and was this king versus
burwell or
nfib versus sibelius that was nfib
versus civilians
i'll get to king versus burwell in a
second um what i said with respect to
nfib
versus sebelius is that the
interpretation
that the majority adopted construing the
mandate
to be a tax rather than a penalty was
not the most natural reading of the
statute
but it was still the reading that
justice roberts got to now you also
criticized as you pointed out by
bringing up king v
burwell another case where the court
ruled in favor of the health law this
was in a 2015
national public radio interview and you
acknowledge that
the result of people being able to
keep their subsidies under the
affordable care act
uh was a would help millions of
americans
yet you praised the dissent by justice
scalia
saying the dissent had quote the better
of the legal argument
is that correct i did say that yes okay
so then would you rule have ruled the
same way and voted with justice scalia
well senator klobuchar one of the
plus sides or the upsides of being an
academic is that you can speak for
yourself
that a professor professes and can opine
but it's very different than the
judicial decision-making process
so it's difficult for me to say how i
would have decided that case
if i had to go through the whole process
of judicial decision making that i was
describing this morning
now having been a judge for three years
i can say
i appreciate greatly the distinctions
between academic writing or academic
speaking
and judicial decision making such that a
judge might look at an academic and say
easy for you to say because you're not
on a multi-member court
you're not constrained by story decisis
um you don't have real parties in front
of you
consulting with litigants consulting
with your clerks
it's just a different process i'm just i
viewed this one so interestingly because
you
were commenting on the public policy
result
which you and my colleagues on the
republican side have said that shouldn't
be above
public policy and you said okay that's
okay but then you were really clear on
your legal
outcome in terms of your view of whose
side you were on you're on scalia's side
and of course that was a side
uh to not uphold the affordable care act
uh which would have been
um kicked millions of people off their
health care in effect because they would
have lost their
subsidies and i just see this as
interesting because of this
uh kind of dichotomy they're trying to
make between
policy and legal and my view is that
legal decisions affect policy i mean i'm
looking at
people in my state that'll deal with
this if the affordable care act
is struck down elijah from saint paul
who was born with cerebral palsy
because of the affordable care act he is
now 16 and is a proud
boy scout casey whose brother lives in
alexandria and his chronic kidney
failure
and he needs a transplant without the
aca
um that'd be that or burnett from the
suburbs of saint paul whose daughter has
multiple sclerosis
depends on benefits under the aca
liliana of fridley who has a 21 year old
son with
autism and needs her children to be able
to stay on her insurance until she's 26
melanie a senior from duluth who's being
treated for ovarian cancer
and needs access to the affordable care
act so my point is that these are
real world situations and so i get
that you're not saying how you'd rule on
these cases so what does that
leave us with here to try to figure out
what kind of judge you would be and i
was
thinking last night of when i was
growing up
we would go up to northern minnesota and
we
didn't have a cabin but we had friends
that did and we would go on these walks
in the woods
with my mom and she loved to show all
the
tracks on that path whether they were
deer tracks and she'd have us figure out
what they were or elk or maybe even a
bear
and we would follow these tracks down
that path
and you'd always think is there going to
be a deer around the corner that we're
going to see
and very rarely was there one but we
would follow
the tracks and so when i look at your
record
i just keep following the tracks that's
what i've got to do and so when i follow
the tracks this is what i see you
consider justice scalia one of the most
conservative judges
in the history of the supreme court as
your mentor
you criticized the decision written by
justice
roberts upholding the affordable care
act that is to me
one big track even if you didn't
consider yourself criticizing him
personally
you criticized the reasoning you then
said in another case about the
affordable care act
uh that you would let you like the legal
reasoning that he
had the better legal argument that
justice scalia had the better
legal argument uh you have signed your
name to a public statement
featured in an ad a paid ad that called
for
an end to what it called the ad called
the barbaric legacy of roe v
wade which ran on the anniversary of the
1973
supreme court decision you disagreed
with long-standing precedent
on gun safety which said that felon
shouldn't be able to get guns
something that was pretty important to
me when i had my old job in law
enforcement this is something that
senator durbin
asked you about you suggested that you
agree with the dissent
in the marriage equality case obergefell
that it wasn't the role of the court to
decide that same-sex
couples had the right to be married i
think this was in a lecture you gave
where
you said the dissent view was that it
wasn't for the court
to decide that people could lobby in
state legislatures
and all this takes me to one point as i
follow those tracks down that path
and it takes me to this point where i
believe and i think the american people
have to understand
that you would be the polar opposite of
justice ginsburg
she and justice scalia were friends yes
but she never embraced his legal
philosophy
um so that is what concerns me and i
want to turn to an area
that where i think justice ginsburg
whose seat we are considering you for
was truly a hero and that was the
area of voting rights
and that was the area of elections
um i think that what did the president
say here
he said september 23 2020
i think this he means the election will
end up
in the supreme court and i think it's
very important that we have nine
justices
i don't think how much clearer we can be
and as i said yesterday
i do not for a minute concede that this
election is going to end up in the
supreme court because people are voting
in droves
as we speak but that is what is on the
mind of the man
who nominated you for this job then he
said
on september 29th of 2020 i think i'm
counting on them
he meant the court to look at the
ballots
indefinitely so
um i know you said earlier in
questions from senator leahy that you
are not going to
commit to whether or not you are going
to recuse yourself
from any kind of an election
case but i do want to point out
that as the president has said these
things and as he has nominated you
that people are voting right now they
are
voting as i said in droves um
do you know how many states or people
are voting right now
judge i think one of my colleagues said
it i don't know
it's uh more than 40 states people are
voting right now as we speak
i think something like 9 million votes
have been
cast do you think it is faithful to our
democratic principles to fill a supreme
court vacancy
this close to an election when people
are still voting
senator klobuchar i think that is a
question for the political branches
okay um that's
that's you're right to answer in that
way um
beyond this immediate election i want to
turn to the supreme court's critical
role
when it comes to the right to vote this
area where
justice ginsburg was such a champion
um senator durbin went over your descent
at length in cantor v bar
where you drew a distinction between
individual rights
and civic rights and you wrote that
historically
felon should be disqualified from
exercising certain rights
like the right to vote and to serve
on juries um so my question is this
actually this next line
where you said these rights belonged
only to virtuous citizens
what does that mean senator i would need
to look at the article to clarify
but as i'm sitting here i don't think i
said felons
should lose voting rights i think what i
was talking about
is that 14th amendment yeah that that
but it wasn't an article just to be quit
right this would
this is your dissent oh my sorry yeah
i think it's your descent in canterbury
yes you're right and it says felons
could be disqualified from exercising
certain rights like the rights to vote
and serve on jurors
but apart from that clause you said
these rights belong only to
virtuous citizens that's what i'm trying
to understand what that means
so the argument in the case um those who
were challenging
heller and those who are arguing on the
side
of the government in the cantor case
is that the seventh the second amendment
is a civic right
um and that is how the supreme court
itself uh
framed the debate as a distinction
between
civic rights and individual rights with
voting being a civic right and in
literature
in the historical literature that was
which was at play in that case
how would you define the word virtuous
because it doesn't appear in the
constitution the senator kind of know
what that means because we're
we're living at a time where a lot of
people are having their voting rights
taken away from them so what's virtuous
okay well senator
i want to be clear that that is not in
the opinion
designed to denigrate the right to vote
which is fundamental
the distinction between civic and
individual rights
is one that's present in the court's
decisions and it has to do with a kind
of a jurisprudential view of what rights
are
and the virtuous citizenry idea is a
historical and jurisprudential one it
certainly does not mean that i think
that anybody gets a measure of virtue
and whether they're good or not
and whether they're allowed to vote
that's not what i said okay now let me
ask you this in a different way because
now let's go to the real world here so
in justice ginsburg dissent in shelby uh
where a 5-4 court struck down a key
provision of the voting rights act she
described the right to vote as a
fundamental right in our democratic
system
and i assume you agree with this because
you just said that not what's not good
to her dissent
you agree with the concept that it's a
fundamental right because you just
as i just said yeah the court has
repeatedly repeatedly said
okay so she also wrote in her dissent
that the constitution uses the words
right to vote in five separate places
the 14th 15th 19th 24th and 26th
amendments
each of these amendments this is still
her talking not me each of these
amendments contains the same broad
empowerment of congress to enact
appropriate legislation to enforce the
protected right
the implication is unmistakable under
our constitutional structure
congress holds the lead reign in making
the right to vote
equally real for all u.s citizens do you
agree with justice ginsburg's conclusion
that the constitution clearly empowers
congress to protect the right to vote